so some people are concerned about
overpopulation
some people are concerned about
us dying out as a human species
both of those people live in us and talk
to me
i know i know
i know uh i i know who they are but yeah
uh what's your in africa is as at the
center of this because there is a
vibrant
huge number probably over a billion
uh yeah we're 1.3 billion people and of
those one billion um blacks
i mean that
where do you land on that
there's a reason
likes why i say i'm haunted
that i'm obsessed
that i'm monomaniacal when it comes to
the free markets
and that i have such a strong sense of
urgency to the point that literally it
is affecting me
and it has to do with the fact that yes
you have the youngest region on earth in
terms of the age of its population
and the growth and the rate at it at
which it's growing
demographic wise
i am not willing to stay there and say
it's a curse for humanity
but it will be a curse for humanity
if we don't
make sure
that these people
our
youth gets
to partake
and what it takes to partake is not much
so if the rest of the world thinks that
get to partake means you have to send
more foreign aid you have to have more
um charity businesses sen i mean charity
um organizations sending stuff away
um of course
you're almost thinking parasites
i'm sorry to say this way if this is
what you're thinking
you're seeing us as no more than
parasites
and if that's what it's going to be
i could see why some people might be
worried about that
although
humans should never be
seen as parasites no matter no matter no
matter
but some people will go there
now
people are here
what are we gonna do dispose of them
that's not an option
so the only option we have left
is to make sure that people partake and
what partaking means is that the people
get included
in them and are
part of the systems that allow for human
flourishing
and it doesn't it's not much in this
case
it's about can we be serious about the
reforms
so we have free market
zones areas
where people where the flourishing can
start can
start to take place
the wealth
that people will need to flourish they
don't need you to give it to them
but it's all about can i let you fly
and you will make it happen for you and
also for me
every young african i see today
i realize how stupid the rest of the
world is
if they're not supporting
what i'm trying to talk about
because even if you don't want to do it
because that's the right thing to do
which i think it is the right thing to
do
yourself in it maybe engage your
selfishness because this person right
there remember i told you
seven billion geniuses everybody is came
to this world with a piece of solution
to the human
problem
this person and that person and that
person
hold something for me because i'm part
of humanity this person might have a
cure
to a cancer that might take my wife out
the wife i haven't met yet but this kid
right here
has it inside
and if i help this if i make sure that
this kid gets a chance to flourish and
to manifest his genius or her genius
that trickled down many years later
comes straight back to serve me and the
love of my life
if we can't see it any other way maybe
let's try to think about it that way
because it becomes a very good
proposition at that point so in this
case
by 2050 lagos nigeria will be the
largest city in the world
the future is african wherever we want
it or not but is it going to be
an african future where you have a youth
being a ticking bomb
because they have not you know there's
no hope
they stay
in poverty because they belong to
nations that don't even understand
sometimes the importance of common law
versus civil law
because they're trapped in um countries
that don't understand that you know you
need to pro you need to
make the legal framework to provide for
better economic freedom so you can
unleash
the the genuineness the awesomeness the
ingenuity the industrious the industry
side of your young people especially of
your women
so that they build all the wealth that
your nation is going to need you to
build and with it the respect that comes
from that
see we have a choice to make and this is
why i feel so so so
restless about this at this point of my
life
we just lost george zaite
george aj is one of the few africans
that i knew who
who put this out that's who i learned
from he's he's gone
and i feel a strong sense of urgency
to not only bring back to the table that
which he has been working on
but to also make sure that it gets seen
that's why being here talking with you
today
it's it's
you have no idea it's
people ask what if someone like you
could say what can i do you did or you
did more than you could ever ever
imagine by just
allowing me to take this message to one
more person
and because if we do this
the change is going to happen somewhere
down the line so verbal effects of all
of that on the uh unlocking the human
potential it's unbelievable all those
people and efforts building cool stuff
amazing things yes yes yes so some are
going to be built stuff authors are
going to work on the reforms so we're
working on reforms by the way i'm
i'm the head of the um africa center for
prosperity of the atlas network the
largest organization in the world uh
working on taking down barriers of entry
for entrepreneurs around the world in
their respective countries
so we're doing great work there are i um
i basically um you know all of them i
obviously all the think tanks we have in
in africa right now um free market think
tanks and we want to promote more of
them to come up and these are local
solutions by local people for their
local problems always that's where we
draw a line and so um
there so we're working on
reforms primarily and making people
understand the free markets and the
importance of it
but it is piecemeal legislation
it takes time
it is hard by the time you accomplish
something here more crap has happened
over here more laws have been pounded
out because you know how they fix a bad
law most of the time whether it's in the
u.s somewhere else put other laws to
kind of undo the law from before but it
keeps stacking up and before you know it
where you should have one thing and it's
clear you have a hundred and they go
against each other and then it's all is
worse so we have piecemeal illustration
but happening you know our teams are
doing really amazing fantastic work
especially the team in ima you know iman
in ghana we have a group now in burundi
the great and the great lakes i mean
people are doing amazing work
amazing work but we need to run faster
so while we keep we help rem running
faster we also have to unlock other
things and right now i'm working on one
of my most
craziest projects
something bold radical crazy for some
people
but i know we're not crazy because
before us singapore has done it
you know uh hong kong has done it
later the most recent china with the
sdzs
the smell um special economic zones
um some of the most radical free market
zones in the world
they've done it and oftentimes within a
generation meaningful change start to
happen right
so
here what i'm working on is this concept
of fast some call it um charter cities
paul romer
others call it um the
um
free cities and i like to call it
startup cities
what these are is for us to think about
okay if peace mean legislation takes
forever at the same while we have
this uh demographic that's growing
faster and faster in africa
there is a discrepancy here between the
the process of the progress we're making
to set the right environment for
business to prop up
and how many more people are coming
to life
literally every day on the continent
there's a discrepancy here and so
the ticking bomb is going faster than
the the process we the progress we can
make this is a problem
so what some of us are working on is
this concept of a startup cities and to
say peace ministries
piecemeal legislation takes too long how
about we continue doing that work which
is essential and critical but at the
same time can we think of zones and i
like to call them also common law zones
where we basically try to
have within the country an area where
for business i'm not talking about
family law or any of that stuff no one
is touching your culture or anything
like that but we're just saying
business-wise
an enclave where you have the best
practices from around the world
including yours
in terms of
what constitute a great business
environment
and allow people
in like it's uh it's you know you get in
freely or nobody's forcing you to go
nobody's forcing you to whatever so
in visa so basically if you were to
think about this um rather unoccupied
plot of land within a country think
dubai on 110 acres of land dubai is
thinking that
uh in their case they're like uh maybe
they decided maybe she'll realize that
the best for business in their case and
they said uh they looked around and were
like wow but common law especially
british common law seems like a very
good one so at that point they decided
for business only
not family or anything like that which
is going to stand there you know sharia
or whatever and so they said
we are going to bring in um
you know uh so they hired a retired
british common law judges to educate the
law and train the people under there and
i'm oversimplifying but at the end of
the day
in uh within a generation
dubai
became
one of the top international financial
centers in the world it is what it is
today
um
so
in the case of the african nations that
that zone can then spread yes it can not
only spread but maybe let's say senegal
if senegal was to go for this here you
have this one and then over there you
have another zone and then what they
start to do is they're not all modeled
the same way because maybe this one is
saying hey we want to attract more i
don't know maybe we want to attract more
um um medical research right this one's
going to be saying maybe we want to
attract more um crypto or maybe it's
gonna be more like us we want to be more
about religious this or whatever you
know what i mean so we wanted to fit
more vis-a-vis and just uh kind of give
the basics the grounds and then watch
the magic happen on it
right and so this is what we're working
on
and the hope there because some people
some people are like
you know i know some people are like you
guys are crazy but hey i'm like no it
it's it's more or less the story of um
you know um
the asian tigers and um most recently
most of uh china's progress economically
speaking because some people might say
well you don't want the china away from
developing you see
even then i say and it's okay
we you can always do better
but we cannot deny
the what the magic
that they have accomplished what they
have accomplished is nothing short of a
miracle 800 million people getting out
of poverty yeah such a good amount of
time so it's not inclu yeah for the
the quality of life for the majority of
the child population yes does something
like that happen without problems of
course not
and so the next person to do something
just actually gets to learn from lessons
from lessons that's all and leapfrog
leapfrog and leapfrog exactly so for me
this is a promise and people like oh but
you guys are crazy but i'm like just
like with everything do you know how
many attempts you took before the first
flight you know the right brothers to
cough do you know how many
and that's important you you try you
crash you try you crash but each time
you're going higher up higher
and you want to get
up for once then you stay up longer and
before you know it you're doing all
types of things so here's the same thing
i tell people
listen all i need
is one success story
and then the sea change
people don't even wait for us yeah
everybody but this is hard because it's
the first time
so but the good news is there are many
groups working on the continent there
are some some um
groups in zambia there's a zone there
folks are doing something like this in
nigeria where we're part of a project
fair in nigeria um uh the one that i'm
most excited about i cannot disclose the
name of the country yet but my god i'm
i'm so excited by it and i just know i
just know lex it's gonna happen in our
lifetime i hope so it's a really
powerful vision and uh you know it's not
being dramatic to say that the future of
humanity uh depends on this that your
success that success in africa
it's such an important continent it is a
century it's the continent where
everything started
and i think it's the continent where
we have that continent has to finally
finally finally thrive we cannot all of
us call ourselves
um
an enlightened society as a whole
when you have such when you have
this it's a humongous continent have you
seen the size of it
you know yeah it's it's it's hard to
fathom actually yeah i forget exactly
and it has such ingenious people you
know sometimes i look at my people
i have to tell you
i'm so proud of him and the young people
especially and you know
he would look at them and you know
somebody said sometimes one day and it
was so true they said
you know we've seen poverty other places
but here
it is just maybe somebody doesn't have
money
but they have dignity
and it's true
yeah so everything else we can handle
and we will handle you have to mark my
word for this this is gonna happen
and um our youth is amazing
you should see them
so full of creativity and it doesn't
matter you know you were telling me what
makes you different many things makes us
all different you know rwandans are very
different from
the west africans that we are um
rwandans for example never dance with
their hips they dance more like you know
with with this part of a body um west
africans hips us it's hips all over the
place all the time and it's you know
more jumping stuff like that in one day
you feel it's more like you know i mean
they remind me more of bala even though
the ballet thing
um rwandans have a sense where you know
they don't eat in uh you know most so
much in public it's not very well it's
something you do
um us we are the west africans we like
to be loud we're almost like the
italians of the continent
and then the ones are more like you know
the swiss of active country even looks
like a switzerland i mean we're so
different from one group to another when
you go to with a congo and you see these
guys they're so crazy we have a dress i
mean they supper so we are a very
different bunch um but you know what i
love about us what i love about my
people
we are
we
we are we we have a manifestation of
what resiliency means
and um
so everything we need is there
everything we need is there
i will say that there's nothing wrong
with the
seed everything
that's wrong with us
is that pot that we put around us
so we're tired of being bonsai people
we
need to be the tallest trees in the
forest that we were designed to be and
so and that can be fixed and that can be
fixed and that's the beauty of it and
that's why i am so i'm almost dizzy
with i get dizzy with uh with hope
i know my history
i know my economics
my fellow humans and all of that and we
know that there's an unfailing recipe
and when it comes to that recipe we have
the hardest part of it
one missing ingredient which is a free
markets
as we go around and talk
and people start to understand
and each country tries to figure out
okay where do we go there from here
i
i know
that i will die
with my continent
having taken
the right shift for a turn i don't have
to see where it ends because i cannot in
my wildest dream imagine where it's
going to end
but i know it's going to be
yeah so all my only job
is to get this message out
and then let my people do with it what
they want to do that's a scale of impact
it's just boundless it's kind of cool i
mean you know sometimes we think about
individual problems and how do we solve
them we look up to certain individuals
like the i don't know steve jobs and
elon musk
but
it's so much more powerful to just
without knowing what they will do
give the freedom
uh to millions to hundreds of millions
of people to do whatever the hell
they're gonna do can you imagine
can you just imagine
you